so who is the brain the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit which no no you
can't see separately I'm telling you
look you have a brain no leg you can't
walk you have leg you have no brain you
can't walk so saying they're all equal
yeah all equal the if they are all equal
in John 17 John 17:3 if I'm on Matthew
it says that the one true God is the
father so Jesus has Jesus has a father I
mean Jesus has a
god Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can hello Brothers oh oh General
commander and chief come here where you
from from Ethiopia you from Ethiopia
okay you Christian or Muslim uh I'm
Christian I'm Muslim alhamd we are both
General yes dep come on are you is this
is this um uniform or you are as no this
is a king sa 100 years ago oh okay so
this is uh you're not are you actual
Soldier do you
[Music]
know so is this more religious no it's
not
religious this is the king sa King ah
King Sati interesting so do you know
anything about
Islam uh no normally I'm Christian so
you're nor Christian do you do you um do
you believe in the Trinity or do you
believe in God as one yeah I think I
think that's that's the difference
between Muslim and chran yeah yeah it's
mainly that we believe yeah we believe
in holy Trinity okay uh the father and
the Son and the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit yeah okay have you ever read the
Quran before have you ever read it
before I haven't read can I give you a
free
copy no thank you no problem no problem
you do you have any questions about
Islam do you know anything about Islam
uh not really because I respect
everyone's religion and uh I would be
happy if someone respect no same like we
are we we believe the Christians we can
marry Christians we can eat from the
Christians how come yeah we are because
you guys are close to us we believe you
are the people of the book you believe
in Jesus we believe in Jesus you believe
in the old the uh the Old Testament yes
so we have a lot of commonality we
believe Jesus we believe he's the
Messiah we believe he's going to kill
the Messiah Antichrist I mean uh we
believe he had a miraculous birth he
done Miracles we have a whole chapter of
the Quran in in in the Quran Mary you
know maram Mary Mary the mother of Jesus
we have a whole chapter in the
Quran now they have to respect us yes
where the generals here are come on yes
so we believe we believe God is one
though so we say God is one he's not a
man because we believe that I'm a man I
am weak I am made out of Bones and you
know flesh and all this kind of stuff so
that's why we believe God cannot be a
man to us we believe it goes against
God's nature like for example do you
believe God is all
knowing like he knows everything uh the
thing is you know if if we don't agree
with the Holy Spirit yes we can't be you
know we we believe in the Holy Spirit
but we believe no no just the holy
spirit means just you
know uh the basic difference I mean the
Holy Trinity you know the Holy Trinity
yeah yes the difference is the Holy
Trinity so if if you don't believe in
Holy Trinity yes do you no yes so that's
the difference you know yeah the basic
thing is the Holy Trinity so if you
don't believe in Holy Trinity we
wouldn't agree you know you know what I
mean but did
just I think Jesus you you you believe
Jesus as a a prophet a prophet yeah we
believe Jesus as a god exactly but the
thing is with us is the reason we okay
okay let me ask you a question uh
Muhammad is a prophet yeah yes so do you
think mes and Muhammad are the same the
same prophets for you say you think
Jesus and Muhammad are prophets you
believe this both prophets they both
prophets yeah so so why why Muhammad
died and no reason but Jesus Di and
Reise okay so we don't we don't so from
our belief we don't believe Jesus
died so so yeah that's what but but but
but even even if he died he didn't die
so where is he now no no let no no no no
let's PA for example how does one dying
let's say for example the prophet
Muhammad is is he died he died okay he's
in the Hereafter Jesus you believe he
died yeah but how does that make one
Superior because okay because if that's
the case Jesus died yes yeah how could
God die that's a big problem cuz if you
say just one one thing if you say
Muhammad died Jesus we believe Jesus is
with God he's going to come back he's
going to kill the Antichrist you know
Antichrist so you think that Jesus is I
mean is superior than Muhammad no so
because you said Muhammad deed Jesus is
going to God so that means there is a
superity okay in profit in your ReliOn
okay so if I die today and you die two
years later how does that make Superior
we believe Jesus going to come back he's
going to die how you come back before he
died no because we believe for do you
believe in God okay
one before one second one just one one
thing if you believe do you believe God
is all powerful of course so why why is
it not possible Jesus is with God is it
impossible for God no no no why is Jesus
special is going before you you know why
because he has to come back and tell the
Christians he never said Trinity and
another thing is if you believe dying
makes him less than God died how could
God die no no that's the difference you
know how is not dead look look what's
your name by the way what's your name
Abraham Abraham my name Ali yes Abraham
the thing is you know if God did we
don't say you know God did for us for
our sins how can God die because if you
say if you say mam died okay let me
finish my sentence because we believe
that I mean we we did that uh a lot of
sins we are human beings we're flesh so
we make we
did uh sins so God will come us because
God is a love so he is sacrified for us
you know he can disappear every creature
but he didn't do that he just giving us
love he died for us he was born and
raised like us then he died you know the
thing is there is a father Sky
wherever there is a son the Jesus and
the Holy Spirit so the Son and the Holy
Spirit cannot be separ I mean separated
we can't see the Holy Spirit and the son
Jesus because the power of
God I mean the holy spirit is upon on
Jesus yeah so that Jesus makes a miracle
so he shows us he de us and he raised
from this no one on no human being
raised from this can you mention one ra
bring life to death yeah yeah no they
did different Prophet they did
they they may do per of they they may do
Miracles not on his own with the
permission of God I know but that we can
see separately the thing is if you don't
believe in Holy Trinity we couldn't you
know have you know just understanding
that is the basic thing I know the rest
is the same yeah true but Abraham you
said that if you said Jesus is superior
because Muhammad died correct yeah
because because this is raised from this
okay and you believe okay Jesus died but
let's go with your logic if you say
Muhammad peace be upon him and Jesus
peace be on him Jesus is superior
because Muhammad died I'm going to say
to that you believe now that as you
believe we don't believe Jesus died we
don't believe Jesus died we believe he's
going to die but let's suppose but to
your logic you're telling me God died so
does that mean God is Jesus Superior
don't say we don't say that this is
Jesus God God is the father okay when we
say God look listen to me when we say
God yeah it means the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit we can't see separ this
hisory separately so when Jesus was on
Earth was he was he the father sorry
when Jesus was on Earth was he the
father he's a son okay he so he was not
the father he's a son he's a son look
okay who sent him what can I explain to
you okay look let me explain to you you
have a brain yeah yeah you have a leg
Yeah if if you lose your leg can you
walk your brain May order you to walk
you can't you can't no no that is my
manmade no that's manade to walk if I
lose my you can use wheelchair but
that's different you can walk you know
you can walk by wheelchair yeah not by
your natural leg it won't be walking
I'll be no no this is a logic this is a
science I'm talking about the science
yeah so you have a brain the brain you
know the brain you know there are cells
we have cells the brain will send us if
you are science student you may know
cere cere like that science I don't want
to go to the details but just the brain
the brain order all all our organs our
body yeah so if if we lose something in
our brain and we have legs yeah we can't
walk because all control is in our brain
okay so we say that God is like that
made like that you know so who is the
brain the Father the Son or the Holy
Spirit which one no no you can't see
separately I'm telling you look I'm
telling you you have a brain no leg you
can't walk okay you have leg you have no
brain you can't talk so you can't see
separate body so you're saying they all
equal yeah all equal
if they are all equal in John 17 John
17:3 from on Matthew it says that the
one true God is the father so Jesus has
Jesus has a father I mean Jesus has a
God and it says the one Jes it doesn't
say God do joh the father no this is
Jesus father joh he says that Jesus has
a God he says the one true God is the
father no look if you take like that
conversation when Jesus is sacrificed on
on a cross he said that
you know he prayed to God some people
even Christians there are different kind
look there are different Christians
believing that they are Christians but
they just you know split because of this
idea so you can't you know you can't
believe you know religion is a belief it
is not a scientific proof listen to me
if you don't believe it you lost so you
know what I mean you believe in your way
I believe in my way that's thank you
brother thank you thank you take care I
mean yeah that was a nice discussion uh
but again it's just you know to us is
very clear I mean who who who was he
praying to you know that's that's that's
an issue you know but anyway it was nice
talk to AB he's a nice man he's a nice
gentleman the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tal tells us that our books will be
given and every little atom weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masjid oh Allah
you helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you built
it donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra Rewards
[Music]